so we had this long period of basically
complete silence on the congressman matt
gates investigation and possible
forthcoming charges then last week we
learned that matt gates ex-girlfriend
had testified before a grand jury and
now things moving significantly more
quickly we have learned that matt gates
ex-girlfriend has been granted immunity
in the sex trafficking probe
investigating the congressman so let's
kind of back it up and reset the entire
thing i believe it was in march of 2021
i remember where where i was we were on
break that week
news uh broke
that matt gates was being investigated
for a number of possible crimes matt
gates is the radical trumpian republican
congressman from florida he's an
absolutely horrible extremist
in every sense of the word and in every
sense of the uh of of
every aspect of him falls under that
category the charges that were being
looked at and remember he has not been
charged with anything yet
that's sort of the whole point of this
it includes
charges stemming from possible actions
involving paying people for money
and the transportation of underage women
between states
which would make it a
sex trafficking case and then as we
expected charges any day
basically nothing happened he did lawyer
up hiring some of the best sex crime
lawyers in the country
but nothing happened and many of you
started to email me asking what's going
on with that is the story dead and of
course i don't know
last week we learned that matt gates
ex-girlfriend testified before a grand
jury and this was one of the first
recent signals that this thing is not
only still going on but could be getting
very serious and now we have learned
that matt gates ex-girlfriend has been
granted immunity in the sex trafficking
probe now there are a number of
different takeaways from this which
we're going to talk about but as cbs
news reports prosecutors granted
immunity to an ex-girlfriend of
representative matt gates before she
testified last week in front of a
federal grand jury gates has been under
investigation to determine if he
violated sex trafficking laws and
obstructed justice in that probe
gates has previously denied all
wrongdoing and has said that he has
never paid for sex nor had sex with an
underage girl the woman who cbs news is
not naming testified last wednesday she
is viewed as a potential key witness
according to two sources one of the
sources said she has information related
to the investigation of both the sex
trafficking and obstruction allegations
cbs news legal analyst ricky clyman says
quote this may be a willing participant
who has a smart lawyer who sought an
immunity deal from the government the
government does not give immunity
blindly so they know what they are
getting in exchange also
the government
or in general people typically don't ask
for immunity unless they were involved
in wrongdoing in some way
and the
hypothetical that's being laid out is
that in florida failure to report child
abuse is a crime
and
this is all speculative but
what we're what is being kind of
discussed is
if part of her testimony
is that she knew of underage
victims as what they are legally of matt
gates
and she didn't report them
she could theoretically be liable for
that because of florida law because in
florida everybody's considered a
mandatory a mandated reporter if she
knew about that she should have reported
it and so the most kind of benign
interpretation of the immunity thing
would be that's what it's about she knew
about it and she's only now talking
about it and she could be liable
obviously it could be far worse than
that in terms of the involvement of matt
gates ex-girlfriend we just don't know
at this point in time but that is what
what's being speculated so this is not
only still going on but it is very very
serious um isabelle kirschner who's one
of these top sex crime defense lawyers
an attorney for gates said to cbs quote
we have seen no credible basis for a
charge against gates
we remain steadfast in our commitment to
challenge any allegations with the facts
and law a source told cbs that as part
of an obstruction probe investigators
are looking into whether gates had a
phone call with the ex-girlfriend and
another woman who was already a witness
in the federal investigation sources
told cbs that the ex-girlfriend and the
other woman traveled to the bahamas with
gates in 2018 along with a third woman
with whom gates was in a sexual
relationship that third woman was 18
but investigators are looking into
whether she was 17
when the sexual relationship began which
would be very bad for matt gates
investigators are also trying to
determine if any of the women were paid
and were illegally trafficked across
state and international lines for the
purpose of sex with the congressman you
know uh sort of like uh common sense
suggests to us
that matt gates shouldn't be such a
compelling person for women to be with
that if he's traveling to the bahamas
with three women one of them was
probably compensated to do it it is you
know we think about it and we go well
it's tough to imagine if you're the
third woman going to the bahamas with
matt gates on some kind of sex trip that
you're doing it willingly but you have
to remember uh 300 million people in
this country matt gates
in some some very general sense seeing
as a guy you know with power and access
to power and at the time had a
relationship with donald trump and
whatever we shouldn't write off the
possibility that someone might have done
this without getting paid but obviously
when you read about it it's sort of like
matt gates what what on earth is going
on here it is increasingly looking like
there is going to be a legal problem for
matt gates coming here and the latest is
immunity for the ex-girlfriend
your internet traffic can be observed by
a number of people your internet service
provider big tech platforms even by the
government and that's why i protect my
internet connection with atlas vpn which
hides my ip address making me invisible
to these intermediaries on the internet
who can track me and sell my data i also
use atlas vpn to watch shows on netflix
and hulu only available in other
countries but the privacy aspect is
what's most important to me if you're
not using a vpn
read about it read about why they're so
important and with just one atlas vpn
account i can protect all of my devices
at the same time you turn it on once you
forget about it you stay anonymous right
now atlas vpn is having a big sale for
my audience giving you 86
off this comes out to a dollar 39 a
month plus you'll get three months free
just click the link below and use the
code pacman